hello Sarah thank you for your marvelous
question if we discuss nothing else
let's discuss your question there's lots
of frustration on both sides and when we
talk about negative perceptions between
America and the Muslim world I think we
have to also address the many layers of
complexity and the many layers of
perception there that are involved there
it's frustrating for me that I'm held to
account accountable for the politics of
every government that precedes me I
don't hold people in the Middle East
accountable for what their governments
do but we all have to pressure our
governments to make better policies so
there's frustration there I'm frustrated
that all of my friends in America have
Middle Eastern friends we feast together
we fast together we read each other's
literature we love each other like
brothers and sisters and still I see
misunderstanding of the effort that's
being made I see every academic
institution in the United States eggnog
yer ating Islamic Studies programs not
as a token gesture but as a matter of
respect and scholarship you will find in
the united states that Middle Eastern
communities of all persuasions and all
religions are welcome they're not chased
so we have a lot of work to do on
perceptions we must speak
people-to-people person-to-person to
overcome perhaps at times what our
governments do badly at times what they
do well I think there are efforts on
many levels may they all continue I do
not believe in a clash of civilizations
I believe in the richness of the
tapestry America is founded on that
principle if it were not so there would
not be so many Middle Eastern people who
call themselves American now but let's
get to the politics it's very
frustrating it's extremely dangerous let
us hope that extremes do not capture
moderates let us hope that we can be
rational let us hope that we can piece
by piece decipher this terrible problem
we have right now and I think it's not
just one thing I think it's many things
but it all comes back to perceptions
what do you think of me what do you
think of what do I think of you and my
part of your family and friendship are
you part of mine you are welcome to this
and I just extend my hand I hope that I
will meet you someday thank you Sarah